bro that like people don't really know
like that [ __ ] really takes you over
like i went from like
170 pounds to like 250 like you know
what i mean that's what q was saying he
was like bro i had to get off that [ __ ]
cause i was getting fat bro you get so
big and it's not even the leanest of
soda cause you're drinking so much soda
so much soda bro two three four five
twenty ounces a day a two liter two two
liters a day all that's going in your
face going in your body and then it
[ __ ] up your inside bro like to a point
where like i was using the restroom and
it was blood oh wow like like they don't
tell you about that part like you'll be
spitting it to be blood and you'll spit
you know and that's normal like that's
normal
and it's like nah bro this can't be how
was it hard to um because you know
obviously with any sort of opiate is not
the easiest thing hell yeah it's hard
but then you just kind of like get
through the withdrawals yeah you'll get
through it it's like i'm not saying you
just go cold turkey that's when it [ __ ]
you up but you go for that's where you
might go to the hospital yeah you're
pouring a pint of daddy like you know
now i'm only doing like you'll do like
an eight a day right then from there
you'll just do like a cup whenever your
stomach start really hurting and then
after that you just kind of like tone it
down to where you're probably only
sipping like
once a day then you sipping like once a
week then it's to like you really don't
even sit like that
yeah i feel like too like that era of
hip-hop where the drug use and the lean
use was ultra glorified
back then i mean fentanyl was always a
thing but i feel like now it's really
yeah that's another thing that slows you
down on a lot of that [ __ ] like like you
might [ __ ] around and wake up yeah but
they don't be putting the fitting all in
the drink but it's just like the price
of the drinks so high and then the price
of drinks are higher you go to pills
they try to get appeals and then the
pills is fake laced you know what i mean
you don't know what you get nowadays you
could so it's just kind of just best to
just stay away from all that [ __ ] bro